[Music]
you don't think of
accomplishing things you work for the
things you really believe in
betty is keeping busy while social
distancing at her los angeles home
she has a positive attitude and enjoys
each day
as for how she plans to celebrate
turning 99
here's what she tells et in this
exclusive quote
you probably didn't ask but i'll tell
you anyway what am i doing for my
birthday
running a mile each morning has been
curtailed by covet as for visitors betty
says she's quote feeding the two ducks
who come to visit me
every day but don't expect betty to have
a zoom birthday party with friends like
ryan reynolds sandra bullock or valerie
bertinelli
the golden girl hasn't learned how to
video conference but she does spend her
time doing crossword puzzles watching
some tv and getting exercise walking up
and down her bedroom stairs
and of course we expect she'll toast her
big day vodka is her favorite i love a
cocktail
if you're blessed with this good health
you should take advantage of it
welcome to the pet set
starring betty white and how's this for
a birthday present
betty's 1970s tv show is being seen for
the first time in 50 years
back in the 70s stars like mary tyler
moore burt reynolds and james brolin
joined her
all of them sharing their passion for
animals
who else could that possibly be but
phoebe's best friend carol burnett
now for the first time betty white's pet
set will be released on digital and dvd
we've gotten to see firsthand betty's
love for animals she once served as a
special e.t
correspondent for a series on celebs and
their pets
and showed us some of her own first i
thought you'd like to meet the members
of my family
this is t.k this is timmy and this is
cricket
happiness is a warm puppy meeting
[Music]
adjourned